thanks to Mubi for sponsoring this video
Christopher Nolan has become known for
his massive visually spectacular films
he comes across as a highly technical
filmmaker uses expensive and complicated
IMAX and 70 millimeter film cameras to
achieve the best possible image quality
uses incredibly technically challenging
practical effects to tell epic stories
that span dimensions of time and space
consciousness and vast conflicts so it
might seem like a little story about a
few burglars shot on black-and-white 16
millimeter film comprising mostly of
handheld footage might not have much in
common with Nolan's later blockbuster
efforts but let's take a closer look at
how Nolan has been technically
challenging himself from the very
beginning and how ideas and techniques
that he learned and used in his first
film are still present in his filmmaking
today you check yourself uh-huh your
source routine was Joe bank this cousin
annoyed
one of the defining characteristics of
Nolan's work seems to be a desire to
challenge himself
technically whether it's the amazing
effort he put into filming the dogfight
sequences and Dunkirk with actual planes
or the crazy practical effects he used
in Inception interstellar and his Batman
films the easy way and Christopher Nolan
don't often mix it's not obvious just
from watching the movie but if you learn
more about the story of how following
was made you can see how this tendency
to push himself and his crew technically
started with following you'd figure out
how to how to do something that looked
pretty good very quickly and that was
very much the production methodology we
transferred over to the film with a bank
following was a technical challenge just
a different kind from the ones that
Nolan faces now I think what following
represents is kind of the the peak of
what I was able to do on my own or just
with friends just using our own
resources and for our own equipment and
sort of using the things around us to
make
who following was shot as a no budget
film and almost everything about it was
crafted to make the film work in spite
of the budgetary and technical
limitations of the movie in the
director's commentary and interviews
when talking about the film
Nolan focuses on these technical
decisions and it's obvious that to him
this was the most interesting aspect of
creating the movie unable to secure
permits to film in public the street
locations were shot guerilla style with
a shaky handheld look the film was shot
in black-and-white to avoid having to
match the color temperature of the cheap
lights they had available to the
temperature of the natural life they
often relied on the story involves a
character that is a loner because actors
and extras are expensive and difficult
to secure the nonlinear structure was
used because it made it easier to edit
around bits of scenes that were missing
or didn't work out and characters often
stand by windows because the light
coming through them was often all Nolan
had to work with some of these
techniques Nolan would carry with him
throughout his career or imitate with
large sets and equipment even long after
it would be necessary while the nature
of the technical challenges Nolan is
facing are different now from the very
beginning those challenges and
discovering unique ways to overcome them
were obviously very compelling to him as
a filmmaker I think that getting a
strong technical grounding was very
important for me and learning how to
photograph things on film expose the
film correctly choose the film stops
those kind of things has served me
extremely well as I've gone on to bigger
and bigger films Christopher Nolan's
obsession with time and nonlinear
storytelling has been dissected in
detail by many other essayists so I
won't linger here long but I can't
completely gloss over probably the most
obvious connection between following and
Nolan's later work following uses three
converging storylines showing us pieces
of all three at the beginning and then
slowly unraveling them revealing
information to the audience bit by
it both time itself and a story's
timeline are things that Nolan is
obviously fascinated by he uses
nonlinear storytelling most explicitly
in memento so we cut between the two the
whole way through
so we alternate seeing here seeing
they're not seeing that and then meet
towards the end of the film and
extensively in the prestige and his most
recent film Dunkirk but he's used
nonlinear narrative to some extent in
almost all of his films and time as a
theme played a heavy role in both
Inception and interstellar at the
beginning of following we get a scene
where exposition happens through a
conversation that's when I started
shattering shattering shattering
following I started to follow people who
if anyone first while on screen we see
images that help us understand that
exposition every magic trick consists of
three parts
thanks this is a technique that Nolan
will return to throughout his
filmography a 58 year old semi-retired
accountant he and his wife had been in
this car accident nothing too serious
but he's acting funny he can't get a
handle on what's going on the doctors
find some possible damage to the
hippocampus nothing conclusive rocky
virgin Sammy can't remember anything for
more than a couple of minutes and we
wound up on the shore of our own
subconscious
we lost sight of what was real
created we built the world for ourselves
he did that for years we built our own
world
we had died the blight came and we had
to burn it and we still had corn we had
acres of corn but uh mostly we had dust
the legend is that there was a mercenary
who worked for a local warlord he fell
in love with the Warlord's daughter they
were married in secret when the world
found out the mercenary was condemned to
this bit listen to this and listen to
this and this
if Nolan's movies have a sound this is
it and it's been there in some form from
the very beginning finally I want to
touch on a reoccurring character trait
in Nolan's films and following were
presented with burglars who are more
interested in the philosophical
implications of their actions than the
average burglar might be it's like a
diary they hide it but actually they
want someone to see it that's what I do
conceal my display besides the same coin
this way they know someone's seen it
that's what it's all about later we'll
see this character trait repeat I'm
using this monster to help other people
just like my father did point is that a
real magician tries to in vain something
new that other magicians are gonna
scratch their heads over you know I'm a
good cop yeah well there's always
something that they can use you know to
get at your credibility you know that
don't talk like one of them you're not
even if you'd like to be to them you're
just a freak like me you you asked me
for inception I do hope you understand
the the gravity of that request the seed
that we plant in this man's mind will
grow into an idea this idea will define
him it may come to change it may come to
change everything about it whether the
character is a magician a superhero
someone who plants dreams and someone
else or an astronaut the philosophical
implications of the characters actions
are always very interesting to those
characters these are the surface
connections between following and the
rest of Nolan's work that I can show you
but I think a majority of its influence
on his career exists below the surface
Nolan never went to film school and
creating following was a formative
experience for him as a filmmaker I
think he continues to carry many of the
lessons he learned working on that film
forward into his filmography and
examining the film and how he made it
sheds light on the things that motivate
his approach to writing ender
awesome movie featured Nolan's following
a couple months ago and if you're
interested in my directors before series
movie will be right up your alley movie
is a movie streaming and download
service but the best part about it is
their excellent curation there's only 30
films available at a time every day one
gets added and one gets taken away each
one is chosen and recommended by a human
one of my favorite parts of the service
are the little blurbs they write
explaining each film's significance and
why you should be interested in it movie
is available globally and there are
never any ads try movie free for 30 days
at MU bi comm slash Thomas flight that's
movie comm slash Thomas flight veer
extended free trial this was the second
part of my directors before series I'm
going to continue putting out videos for
the series but since they involve
examining a director's entire
filmography they take a little longer to
make so subscribe and keep your eyes
peeled for the next episode and check
out the videos I'll put out in the
meantime